Oh finalmente siamo sul video conclusivo
dell'anno ho comprato una macchina è una
Mustang con il kit estetico Shelby
piccolissima premessa io questo video in
realtà di base non volevo farlo
bellissimo che dico questa frase anch'io
ogni tanto perché la Mustang una
macchina che a me piace che volevo
assolutamente prendermi prima o poi
Infatti adesso l'ho presa però quello
che voglio dirvi è che questo qua non
sarà un video kiro sulla macchina che ho
preso in pista guardi qua di là non me
ne frega neanche una sega perché a me di
motori non me ne frega un cazzo quindi
non è un video Per appassionati di
motori questo Anche perché l'ho presa
con le caratteristiche che volevo io
quindi col cambio automatico robe del
genere quindi non mi cagate u cazz
Semplicemente ho preso quello che a me
piaceva questo video in realtà è stato
fatto Perché all'inizio non volevo farlo
ma poi ho detto è un'occasione di
intrattenimento persa se non lo faccio
più che altro per le Reaction tra cui la
mia quando l'ho presa infatti partiamo
proprio con questo e poi passiamo al
Reaction di tutti quanti Let's go
Eh devo fare così quando dico Let's go
perché sennò non cambia la scena adesso
andiamo
la patente No io sto vicino quanto
voglio io non sono un fissato di
macchine però quando ho guidato questa
macchina in America che si chiama
Mustang sono rimasto abbagliato da
cotanto a bellezza Allora ho detto mi
compro una vasta che in Italia è
difficilmente trovabile però ne abbiamo
trovata una e sembra incredibile Quindi
vado siamo arrivati alla concessionaria
ragazzi ed è il momento in cui vi
presento la mia bimba devo darle un nome
non siamo
Quindi questi sono soldi veri che sto
spendendo Eccolo qua
[Musica]
stavo facendo un inquadratura Fammi fare
qua
ora Fammi fa Non può essere la mia
macchina
questa è la mia macchina
[Musica]
Mamma mia Per non dire porco Dio
le gallette sono i biscotti migliori per
fare colazione alla mattina io sono
mangio quella Eccoci qua
93 euro Stiamo uscendo dalla
concessionaria con la macchina come si
fa in GTA bello sto GTA 6 una grafica
veramente incredibile Porca [ __ ] Sono
convinto che se per caso questa macchina
mi esplode non me la trovo per strada
restaunata non penso me lo confermi Già
te lo confermo poi ragazzi Questa è
quando l'ho presa giorno dopo Mattia che
è il ragazzo che mi ha aiutato appunto a
prenderla a trovarla come la volevo io
tutti gli optional che volevo io un
casino Ti amo Mattia Ti amo lascio il
link Tra l'altro di Mattia qua sotto che
mi ha dato una mano il giorno dopo con
lui l'ho portata a Torino dai miei
genitori siamo andati con due macchine
per vedere la Reaction sono praticamente
dietro la mia macchina perché la stiamo
portando a Torino belle feste di Natale
ho deciso di farla vedere ai miei
parenti e quindi Mattia mi sta dando una
mano io sto portando la mia vecchia Se
per caso incidente con la mia stessa
macchina come lo spiega l'assicurazione
che Lorenzo Ostuni ha danneggiato l'auto
di Lorenzo Ostuni
Va bene
va bene
sembra un video di film questo Oddio che
succede Eccolo eccolo
Stiamo andando ragazzi a casa mia la
casa Quella dove ho fatto i primi video
quella cosa con la mia cameretta Stiamo
andando a far vedere la macchina ai miei
genitori È una sorpresa e farò scendere
mio padre con una scusa di come aiuta a
portare i regali su
e poi lo faccio scendere e sono con la
Mustang questa cosa farà molto ridere
vediamo cosa succede
Va bene Ciao papi
Mamma mia che roba Ma è uno spettacolo
veramente ragazzi che è mio amico cosa
Fast and Furious
Hai sentito mamma mia Ok ragazzi Qua
siamo da Niki che Conoscete tutti come
laggiù nei miei migliori amici è
appassionato anche di auto quindi
vediamo la Reaction della reazione
number one che voglio vedere perché
[Musica]
Ma di che cosa stiamo parlando Ma
secondo te ha senso che io guidi una
macchina così senza la Barbati
Adesso è il momento in cui ci fa un
giretto Sei il primo che la guida
una Mustang a Venaria che la Mustang la
fanno a Los Angeles non esiste l'hanno
portata all'America dalla California
dalla California
Mamma mia ci rendiamo conto che sto
guidando una mappa
la sensazione che sei per caso faccio
andare il piede un po' più giù
sull'acceleratore partiamo
Non accelerare sono finiamo nel campo e
butto la macchina posteriore
[Musica]
ragazzi Te gusta bellissima che ho fatto
le foto alla D che si è seduto sulla
macchina ed è rimasto il culo
comunque siamo allo stadio della Juve
sono bravissimo Ti amo e soddisfazioni
mi darà dei ragazzi non esistono
speriamo anche la Juve Anche se dubito
prima di concludere Questa è stata
Reaction io volevo ringraziare anche
Dexter Sto proprio parlando del vostro
caro Dexter e mi ha dato una super mano
per quanto riguarda la Mustang perché
anche lui ne ha una da non so quanto
Grazie Dexter E a proposito eh Lo
chiamiamo al volo per chiedergli due
consigli Eccolo qua dottore Allora io
avrei due domande due o tre domande al
volo da farti Siccome io ancora non sono
ben sicuro di come utilizzare la
macchina Volevo chiederti delle tue
esperienze che hai avuto in un paio di
occasioni la prima quando tu vai a fare
la spesa all'Eurospin con la Mustang
dove la metti la metti davanti alla
porta dell'Eurospin
dentro la corsia Ok capito perfetto
Questo è un po' più seria Io ho notato
che effettivamente
è lunga Tu hai mai trovato difficoltà
nel parcheggiare in generale proprio al
di là
Ok
quindi vai tranquillo però è un pochino
fastidiosi sensori d'autunno ti lascio
la tua pasta al pomodoro e ci sentiamo
quando siamo più freddo Ciao bello
Quindi ragazzi ci ho fatto un regalino
di Natale Insomma una roba una roba così
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto Ci
vediamo al prossimo episodio iscrivetevi
al canale lasciate un bel mi piace e
come sempre ci vediamo ad un prossimo
video bella ragazzi